so now when we go further it says part b
the first rope is strong uh what does
that mean well the whole idea here is
that this tension
um you know if it exceeds a certain
amount it'll snap right it only has a
certain capacity but
what this the question is telling us in
much the same way
that the word light means there's no
weight that you need to worry about
uh the word strong here indicates it's
like got
you know infinite tension it's got so
much tension you don't need to worry
about it so therefore
um the first rope i can disregard the
second rope will break
if the tension in it exceeds 98 newtons
so i need to think about
this rope here t2 and i need to find the
maximum value of m for which the flower
pot will remain in equilibrium so
you can imagine if you have a super
light flower pot it's not pulling down
much at all
so therefore the upward forces just keep
it staying still there's not enough to
um
you know rip it off the ceiling but if i
exceed if my value of m
exceeds the tension in t2 i don't have
to worry about t1
then it's going to snap and the flower
pot will not remain in equilibrium
anymore so how do i do this well
in much the same way that i did part a
by thinking about the horizontal
forces being in balance i'm going to do
the same thing with part b
but doing it vertically right that's
what i was leaving out here i did all of
the x's
here and up here i'm going to be taking
care of the y's
so i should do my expressions here so i
can say well let's just have a look at
this diagram while i'm at it
y1 is this diagram this length here
right
so if this is 30 degrees there's a 30
degrees here it's alternate angles on
parallel lines
so if there's a 30 in here then y1 is
adjacent
and t1 is the hypotenuse right so much
the same way
that it's sine 30 gives me this
relationship i'm basically just going to
do cos 30
right so i'll stick with red since
that's the color i use for that triangle
cos 30 degrees equals adjacent that's
what we just
established on hypotenuse so y1
is going to be equal to i'm multiplying
t1 to the other side
but cos 30 degrees is root three on
two t one okay so there's in that
triangle and in much the same way
i'm going to be doing the same thing in
the blue triangle but you're probably
getting a sense here
instead of sine 60 it's going to be cos
60 and that's going to be my
half so let's do that laying this out
nice and neatly
cos of 60 degrees equals y2
on t2 so that gives me y2 being the
subject
t2 on 2 and hopefully there's kind of
this symmetry here that you recognize
from part a
all right now in much the same way i'm
going to do this reasoning here right
this was making a statement about being
in equilibrium horizontally but now i'm
thinking about being in equilibrium
vertically so i need to think about what
my vertical forces are and what they all
sum to so here i've got y1 and
y2 both heading up and then i've got
m the mass times gravity which they're
giving to me is 9.8 going in the
opposite direction
downward so y 1 plus y 2 going up
m times gravity going down so therefore
i can say
y 1 plus y 2
equals the mass times 9.8 was their
particular value
okay so everything's balanced out
vertically now this point here i'm just
going to take these two results here and
here and substitute them in
so that gives me root 3 on 2
t1 plus uh
t2 on 2 equals 9.8
am all right now what am i trying to do
here i've like written a bunch of
equations that's great but what am i
trying to solve for
if you return back to the question we
remember that the first rope is strong
that's another way of saying i don't
really need to worry about
t1 okay it's sort of so large that it's
not going to
figure in whether the flowerpot's mass
is going to be a problem
what i really need to think about is t2
so you can see in this equation i've got
t1 and t2
but what i want to do is i want to
substitute out t1 get rid of that you
don't need to worry about it there's no
solving for that required
t2 is what i want to solve for so i need
to get rid of all my t1s replace them
with t2s now what that tells you is if
you have a look back up here
um i can't use this substitution um as
it is stated because if i substituted t2
into here
i'd get rid of t2s and end up with t1s
but i just established i don't need to
worry about t1 it's the
you know sufficiently large quantity
that i can i can ignore it so therefore
what i'm going to do is just
slightly shift this around i can say
that t1
equals root 3 times t2
and this is what i'm going to substitute
this line right here
i'm going to substitute that there and
then i'll just have an equation that's
all about t2s
so i'm going to call that let's just
call that from in fact i don't need to
label it because i'm just
going to say from part a so i'm going to
say but
from part a
i'm going to say t 1 equals root 3 t
2 therefore alright let's do our
substitution now so i've got root 3 on 2
times root 3 times t 2
plus t 2 on 2 equals 9.8
times the mass all right now this point
here
um what am i trying to solve for i've
got two unknowns i've got t2
and then i've got the mass have a look
back at the question because it will
guide us right
it says the second rope will break if
the tension in it exceeds 98 newtons so
t2 can go up to 98 and
if i go past that then i'm in trouble
i'm trying to find the maximum value of
m
so m's are unknown so i still want m to
be in our equation
it's going to be a substitution for t2
that i'm going to do
right so i can say i need i think i can
just sneak it in up here
let's go this way okay um i want to say
um you know rope will break
after t2 equals
98 so i'm going to substitute in t2
equals 98 because that's like just
before it breaks right
so therefore i can say root 3
on 2 times root 3
times 98 plus 98 on
2 equals 9.8 m so i've satisfactorily
gotten rid of every other unknown except
for m and that's what i'm going to solve
for
now you can see on the left hand side it
will help me if i tidy things
up i'm not going to do 98 divided by 2
because i've got 98s flying around so i
might as well try and um
collect a few like terms if i pull that
98 out the front what does it leave me
with and the answer is
this is root 3 times root 3 so that's 3
all on
2 and i got that on 2 from here and then
because i pulled out that factor of 98
that just leaves me with a half
there so that's 9.8 over that side
what am i getting well this is going to
be
4 over 2 which is 2. so therefore i've
got
um 2 on this side i'm going to go ahead
and divide through
by 9.8 on both sides
as well so that gives me instead of 98
here
that 9.8 being divided gives me a 10
like so so there's my m and make that
the subject that gives me
20 and of course newtons are a unit
which
include kilograms in them so actually
that mass is 20
kilograms so have a think about how we
went through that right i had to make
sure i used my diagram effectively
resolve my forces use some trigonometry
and then i wanted to make sure i
combined everything
you know look at the horizontal forces
and how they balance
look at the vertical forces and how they
balance and then off you go